that's to work go ahead this is
interesting you can set it on the ground
okay if you got good aim at least oh my
gosh so I just pull that is go hold
right there okay and pull down there you
go you got a little
bit you're going to be here a
while Chuck I got it oh there you go
there you go Chuck
Chuck there you go there you go Chuck
let back off on it a little bit this
thing will take hey hey calm down Bessie
Rosie Rosie okay close enough
oh hey hey calm
down you're a natural
milker hey and then let off on it so she
can fill back up and then do it again oh
I see now let it off hey calm down
Bessie
okay very impressive congratulations
Kenny I'll pass I'm from New Y I'm from
New York City sir what does that matter
New York City we I'm from the concrete
jungle New York's the third da state